Today’s protagonist is
the
Generalisimo Francisco Franco, who ruled Spain
from 1939 to 1975 with the title of ‘Caudillo’,
leading one of the longest running dictatorships
in Europe.
He is best remembered as the leader of the
Nationalist faction, the military insurgency
which opposed the Republican government in
the Spanish Civil War.
But how did he rise through the ranks and
seized control of a movement that he had not
initiated?
How did he rule Spain after the war and how
did he orchestrate the transition back to
the Monarchy?
We are going to cover these and other aspects
of Franco’s life in today’s Biographics.
Before we start, a disclaimer: an extensive
account of Francisco Franco’s life implies
telling the History of a complex conflict
and of a whole nation for more than 40 years.
So, we are going to skip some chunks in today’s
video.
If you think we have missed an important event,
post your suggestions in the comments – make
sure that you name the protagonist, or protagonists
of these events, and we may consider future
videos about them.
Bueno, ya he charlado demasiado.
Empecemos con la historia del Caudillo!
The Small Cadet
Francisco Franco Bahamonde was born on the
4th of December 1892, in the town of El Ferrol,
North Western Spain.
He had two brothers and one sister, born into
a family that for generations had served the
once glorious Spanish Navy.
Sister Pilar described him as a very quiet
and serious boy, physically very thin.
In his childhood Francisco had two obsessions:
his studies and his mother, with whom he had
a very tight relationship.
Francisco’s mother Maria del Pilar was an
austere and devout woman, who imbued Francisco
with a deep faith in religion and in the importance
of the Church in Spanish society.
His father was more interested in alcohol
and extra-marital affairs, a life-style which
Francisco perceived as debauched and actively
avoided throughout his life.
In 1898 the once mighty Spanish Empire was
reduced to a handful of colonies following
the defeat in the Hispano-American war, which
cost them Cuba, Puerto Rico and the Philippines.
The remnants of the defeated Spanish fleet
returned to El Ferrol, marking a period of
mourning for the whole community and especially
for the six-year-old.
This may have instilled in him a desire to
restore the glory of the Empire.
The other effect of the destruction of the
fleet was a decline in available spots for
the Naval Academy for several years.
The Navy would have been Francisco’s natural
destination, but he had to settle for an Army
career instead.
In 1906, aged 14, Francisco enlisted in the
Toledo Army academy.
The new cadet was so small, his voice so shrill
that he quickly became victim of the academy’s
bullies.
His frame was so frail that the instructors
had to modify his training rifle to make it
lighter to carry.
Francisco made up for his physical shortcomings
with determination and hard work, although
he did not display particular leadership qualities.
He graduated in 1910 with a modest 251st place
out of 312 cadets.
The Spanish military was saturated with officers
at that time and opportunities for career
progression were scarce.
In 1912 Francisco took the calculated move
of volunteering for a post in Spanish Morocco,
the last colony, as the only chance to progress
in ranks.
His experiences in Africa would be key in
shaping his later life.
He later declared:
“Without Africa, I could not explain who
I am”
El Novio de la Muerte
The Kingdom of Spain was engaged in a brutal
colonial war against the rebel tribes of the
Rif mountain range.
In this conflict Lieutenant Franco displayed
qualities so far kept hidden: tenacity and
physical courage.
Lieutenant Franco was in charge of a company
of Moroccan colonial troops, loyal to the
Spanish crown.
He was able to maintain a ruthless discipline
amongst his soldiers, even when under heavy
enemy fire.
On one occasion one of his troops refused
to eat his rations and threw them at another
officer.
Franco had him executed by firing squad.
It is alleged that he applied this ruthlessness
also against civilians, using terror tactics
to quell the rebellion.
The officers of the Spanish army in Africa
at that time were nicknamed ‘Novios de la
Muerte’, which can be translated as ‘the
grooms (or boyfriends) of Lady Death’.
This was because of the high casualty rates
amongst their ranks.
Franco apparently disregarded the fear of
death, often leading from the front almost
suicidal attacks against entrenched rebels.
In 1917 Franco had already been promoted Major
and was ordered back to Spain to break a strike
of coal miners in the northern region of Asturias.
During his stay in Oviedo, the capital of
the region, he got engaged with Carmen Polo,
despite opposition from her family of wealthy
merchants.
Back to Morocco in 1918, on the 28th of June
he was shot in the stomach, an almost certain
appointment with Lady Death.
While bleeding out on a stretcher he called
out to a doctor, but he was refused treatment.
According to the doctor, it would have been
futile.
Franco then grabbed a rifle and pointed it
at the doctor, threatening to shoot him if
he was not treated.
The medic changed his mind and had him evacuated
to the field hospital.
Against all odds, he fully recovered.
The native troops followed him with blind
loyalty afterwards.
In October of 1920 Franco was second-in-command
of the Tercio de Extranjeros, the Spanish
Foreign Legion recently founded by Lieutenant-Colonel
Millan Astray.
Millan introduced as such the credo of the
Tercio:
“Death in combat is the greatest honour.
You die only once.
Death arrives without pain and is not so terrible
as it seems.
The most horrible thing is to live as a coward”
The Tercio became known for its effectiveness,
courage and brutality.
One of Franco’s soldiers, described as such
their operations:
“When it attacked, the Tercio knew no limits
to its vengeance.
When it left a village, nothing remained but
fires and the corpses of men, women and children”
In 1923 Franco became commander of the Tercio,
shining for his strategic and administrative
ability.
On the 23rd of October he married Carmen in
Oviedo, with a representative of King Alfonso
XIII present at the wedding.
They would have only one daughter, Carmencita,
born the following year.
After 14 years of service in Morocco, the
once mediocre Lieutenant had progressed so
quickly that he returned to Spain a Brigadier
General.
Aged 33, he was the youngest General in Europe
since Napoleon.
He had also become something of a celebrity,
frequenting elite circles and even starring
as himself in the movie ‘La Malcasada’
of 1926.
This curious film, dealing with a real-life
divorce case, featured many intellectuals,
politicians and military leaders of the time.
Starring alongside Franco can be seen his
old commander Millan Astray, who would later
become Nationalist propaganda chief during
the Civil War.
And even Miguel Primo de Rivera, who was ruling
Spain as a military dictator from 1923 with
the blessing of the King.
Franco’s celebrity status and Carmen’s
connections gave him access to the elitist
world, but he did not enjoy their pleasures.
He preferred to relish the traditional and
austere values he had learned from his mother,
which he imparted to his cadets at the new
military academy in Zaragoza.
But despite his best efforts for a return
to tradition, Spanish society was changing
around the young General.
End of an era
From the bottom up, Spanish society was shaken
by the rise of leftist movements opposing
the traditional pillars of the Monarchy, the
Catholic Church and owners of large land estates.
At the top, Primo de Rivera’s dictatorship
was failing due to his ill-conceived economic
policies resulting in high taxation, unsustainable
public debt and raising inflation.
He was forced to resign in January 1930.
In 1931 Alfonso XIII agreed to democratic
elections, which saw the victory of the left.
In April, the King abdicated.
The Spanish Republic was founded and a new
constitution ratified.
According to Franco’s niece, this was a
personal catastrophe for him, as he did not
believe in democracy nor in a multi-party
system.
But the new Government was a fragile one and
in November 1933 it was replaced by a conservative
coalition, who appointed General Franco as
Commander in chief of the Army.
The left continued to cause unrest, though:
in 1934 it was launched another massive strike
of coal miners in Asturias.
Franco was tasked with restoring order in
the area.
He commanded the Tercio to take charge of
the strikers.
2000 protesters were killed or wounded, many
more deported to Morocco.
But his actions had the unintended consequence
of rallying the left wing parties into a strong
coalition, called ‘Frente Popular’ or
‘People’s Front’.
In February 1936 new elections were convened.
This time it was the leftist People’s Front
to secure a victory.
The new government ensured that conservative
generals were not close to the seat of power.
Franco was dispatched to Tenerife in the Canary
Islands, 2000 km from Madrid.
The Government kept close tabs on him, by
wiretapping his phone and checking his mail.
In the meanwhile, unrest and violence were
spiralling in the country.
The supporters of the leftist government soon
gave way to excesses, especially against Catholic
institutions.
Churches were being burned and priests murdered.
Behind the scenes, a group of Generals was
plotting a ‘golpe militar’ or military
coup.
Franco did not get involved at this stage,
coldly calculating the risks involved.
The leaders of the plot were General Sanjurjo
and General Mola.
Mola, the chief planner of the coup, had a
scheme to involve Franco in the ‘Bando Nacional’,
or Nationalist Forces.
The plan involved dispatching a plane from
London to the Canaries, to then smuggle Franco
into Morocco, where he would lead the Tercio
to join the insurrection.
While on the 11th of July the plane was flying
to Gran Canaria, Franco sent an encrypted
message to Mola, refusing to participate in
the coup.
But on the 13th, right wing politician José
Calvo Sotelo was murdered by the Republican
police, which gave to the insurgents the motivation
to proceed with their plans at all costs.
Franco was finally convinced.
On the 19th of July 1936 he travelled in civilian
disguise to the Moroccan colony.
The African Army, numbering 30,000, swore
loyalty to Franco and to his cause.
But how could he ferry such an army to Spain,
when the Navy was loyal to the Republic and
was patrolling the straits of Gibraltar?
This is when he secured help from Fascist
Italy and Nazi Germany.
The Italian and German air forces came to
help Franco: by organising 800 flights they
managed to ferry his forces to mainland Spain.
The hopes of the insurgents for a quick resolution
of the coup did not materialise.
What had just started was a long and bloody
conflict, the Spanish Civil War.
The insurgents also had a leadership problem:
their commander General Sanjurjo had died
in a plane crash on the 20th of July, being
replaced by military Junta only formally led
by the elder General Cabanellas.
In the meanwhile, Franco had reached Seville
and quickly led his army northwards, facing
only the resistance of civilians.
His African Army soon reached Badajoz, near
the Portuguese border.
After conquering the city, Franco embarked
in a political cleansing of the area.
As witnessed by Portuguese journalist Mario
Neves, hundreds of prisoners were rounded
up in the local bull-fighting ring and executed
by firing squad.
Franco continued his march towards Madrid,
but in September he ordered a diversion to
Toledo, south of the capital.
In Toledo a small garrison of Nationalists
was besieged by the Republican army inside
the Alcazar, the castle which housed the very
military academy in which young Francisco
had graduated.
Franco’s army defeated the Republicans,
but he only joined them the following day,
27th of September, in full view of the news
cameras.
He had realised that this was more of a PR
event than a simple military victory.
Toledo was not only home to the Military Academy,
it was also the religious capital of Spain.
By appearing as the liberator of Toledo Franco
had portrayed himself as the defender of Spanish
traditional institutions.
A coup within a coup
On
the
same evening, Franco travelled to the city
of Caceres.
Here, General Millan Astray and General Yague
announced that now the whole Nationalist Army
was under the sole command of General Franco.
So far Francisco had been leading only the
African Army in the south, while General Mola
was in command in the North.
All the generals, except for the old Cabanellas,
thought that a unified leadership would improve
their war efforts.
Franco was one of the candidates, but he was
not sure about taking the mantle.
It was thanks to the scheming of his own brother
Nicolás that he eventually accepted.
Nicolás first pressured Yague into convincing
Francisco to lead all armies.
Yague issued a vague threat to Franco: if
he didn’t accept the role, the Junta would
appoint somebody else.
Nicolás also orchestrated a meeting of eight
leading Generals, including Franco, in Salamanca,
on the 28th of September 1936.
The purpose of the meeting was whether to
concentrate on one single person both military
and political leadership of the Spanish State
during the Civil War.
Except for two Generals, everybody voted for
Franco to be the leader of the Spanish State,
a term which indicated the Nationalist controlled
territory.
Franco now had become the Generalisimo of
all armed forces and head of the Government.
He took on the title of Caudillo, an ancient
style for ‘Leader’.
In theory, he only had a mandate for the duration
of the war.
But Nicolás cleverly redacted the Official
Bulletin bearing the decision, so that this
time limitation was omitted.
The Franco brothers had outsmarted the other
generals, a real coup within a coup, which
ensured total power for life to the once reluctant
insurgent.
Continuing the War
By October 1936 Nationalist forces were in
control of the roughly one third of Spanish
territory, mainly in the West and North of
the Country.
But Madrid was still out of Franco’s reach,
despite intensive air and artillery bombings.
At this time, the Republican government secured
support from Stalin.
Now, every side of the conflict could rely
on help from powerful dictatorships.
This War would not spare civilians, it was
a total war in which many of the horrific
tactics of WWII would be tested.
Atrocities were perpetrated on a massive scale,
on both sides.
Franco and the other Generals enacted a policy
of purging captured cities, following the
example of Badajoz.
The Republicans were also active in executing
members of the clergy, Nationalist prisoners,
Nationalist sympathisers and even themselves,
as a result of infighting among disparate
factions – most notably in Catalunya.
It is estimated that by the end of the war
the Nationalists had executed 75,000 people,
compared to 55,000 murdered by Republicans.
In February 1937, Franco attempted to take
Madrid by frontal assault, in the Battle of
the Jarama river, but was stopped by the International
Brigades of foreign volunteers.
It is interesting to note that 5,000 Germans
and 3,000 Italians fought against Franco,
joining the International Brigades in support
of the Republic.
These brigades were 60,000 strong at their
peak.
In March Franco approached the capital from
North East, capturing Guadalajara first.
An Italian Corps took the city and then moved
quickly to Madrid, but was repelled by a Republican
and Soviet tank counterattack.
Operations progressed for the Nationalists
in the north: In August 1937 they captured
the Northern stronghold of Santander with
help from Italian regular army and Blackshirts.
This helped consolidate their territories
in the North.
In the meanwhile, the German Condor Legion
and the Fascist Air Force had been perpetrating
the first large carpet bombings of civilian
targets over Durango, Barcelona, Madrid and
most notably, Guernica, on the 26th of April
1937.
But all in all, despite decisive support from
his allies, Franco’s progress was slow.
German leadership was frustrated by this and
suspected it was a calculated move on his
side: Franco’s strategy was to firmly consolidate
his own political power before advancing on
new territories.
The situation for the Republicans became dire
in the 2nd half of 1938.
In July they engaged the Nationalists in a
protracted battle on the river Ebro, in the
North East.
It lasted 113 days and claimed more than 13,000
casualties on both sides.
The Nationalists, 600,000 strong, could take
the hit, the Republicans, less so.
In September of 1938 the International Brigades
withdrew from Spain, while Mussolini sent
even more aircraft and artillery to Franco.
On the 26th of January 1939, Barcelona fell
to the Nationalists.
The President of the Republic, Manuel Azaña,
fled to France.
On the 27th of February, British Prime Minister
Neville Chamberlain was the first European
democratic leader to recognize Franco’s
Government as legitimate.
On the same day Azaña resigned and by the
1st of April all Republican forces had capitulated.
It was the end of the war.
Half a million people had died, 2% of the
total Spanish population.
But the death toll would not stop there.
As a sole ruler, dictator or Caudillo, of
the Spanish State, Francisco Franco could
not tolerate dissent.
After the war had ended, he continued his
policy of purging the country from enemies
of his regime via executions ruled by military
tribunals.
Sources differ, but it is alleged that between
30,000 and 200,000 dissidents were executed
by Franco’s regime.
The Caudillo and The Fuehrer
Following the beginning of WWII in Europe
there was a debate as to whether Spain should
join the Axis powers in their fight.
On the 23rd of October 1940 Franco and Hitler
met in Hendaye, in Southern France.
Franco owed much to the Germans, but during
that meeting he did not commit to an active
participation in the war.
This decision was considered a wise one, and
defended by Francoist supporters over time.
The Spanish military and industrial capabilities
had been exhausted by the Civil War, and they
were not in shape of joining another conflict.
However, a member of Von Ribbentrop’s staff
…
[Editing suggestion: show a photo of Joachim
Von Ribbentrop with the caption ‘Joachim
Von Ribbentrop – German Minister for Foreign
Affairs’]
… Interviewed by the BBC reported that there
had been a previous meeting in Berlin.
Ribbentrop had met with Franco’s foreign
affairs minister, Ramón Serrano Suñer.
The minister proposed to join the Axis, in
exchange for a large chunk of North African
territory to rebuild the Spanish Empire, but
at that time the Germans had not been impressed
by the offer.
At the Hendaye meeting, again Franco offered
his participation in the war, in exchange
for all of French Morocco, Algeria and Tunisia.
Hitler could not accept these demands and
the negotiations did not progress.
The Fuehrer was furious.
This is when he famously said that he’d
rather have four teeth pulled off than having
another talk with Franco.
Later in the war Franco was astute enough
to maintain an equidistant neutrality with
both Axis and Allies.
For example, on the one hand he allowed allied
pilots downed over Spanish territory to re-join
their countries, and he never made a move
on Gibraltar.
On the other hand, he allowed Italian Navy
frogmen to launch raids on Gibraltar from
Spanish ports.
By 1941, he was maintaining good trade relations
with the US and the UK, but in that summer
he allowed a contingent of 47,000 volunteers
to join Operation Barbarossa against the Soviet
Union.
This contingent, known as ‘La Division Azúl’,
or Blue Division, was recalled in October
of 1943, when it was clear that the war on
the Eastern front was a lost cause for the
Axis.
This marked Franco’s opportunistic shift
towards the Allies in the latter part of the
War.
A Gradual Transition
After the war Franco came under considerable
pressure to restore the monarchy.
In 1947 Franco announced a referendum to let
the Spanish people decide.
The vote confirmed a preference for the monarchy,
however the ever-astute Franco, while accepting
the decision, declared himself as lifetime
regent, with the privilege of appointing a
further regent, or a King, before his death.
Following the death of Alfonso XIII in 1941,
the natural heir to the throne was his third
son Don Juan of Bourbon, Count of Barcelona.
Don Juan’s eldest brothers had both renounced
the succession.
Franco however was under pressure from two
components of his power base: the Falangist
and the Carlist movements.
The Falangists were anti-monarchic, while
the Carlist supported another branch of the
Bourbons.
Franco managed to placate both by selecting
as future king the son of Don Juan, named
Juan Carlos.
Reluctantly, Don Juan agreed and in 1949 the
ten-year-old Juan Carlos travelled to Madrid
to begin his studies and training as future
Monarch.
While planning for his succession, Franco
had to think about rebuilding his country,
weakened by the war and internationally isolated.
International community saw with suspicion
his regime, a remnant of fascist dictatorships
from before the war.
In fact, Franco’s regime did offer sanctuary
to many former Fascists and Nazis - a prime
example being former SS Commando Otto Skorzeny,
managing a thriving business in Madrid.
Franco embarked on a project to reconcile
the opposing factions of the Civil War: the
‘Valle de los Caidos’, or Valley of the
Fallen.
This is a monumental shrine, built over 20
years, not far from Madrid.
It is topped by a gigantic cross, taller than
the Eiffel Tower and it houses the remains
of 50,000 Nationalist and Republican soldiers.
Franco’s intention was to commemorate the
fallen, heal the rift between enemies and
lay a promise not to engage in further civil
conflict.
The intention was good, although some sources
claim that it was built thanks to forced labour
of Republican prisoners.
Looking externally, Franco sought to re-establish
ties with the West.
His strong anti-Communism stance made him
especially popular with the United States,
and they backed Spain’s entry into the United
Nations in 1950.
The relationship with the US was cemented
in 1953: Franco and President Eisenhower signed
an agreement that enabled the United States
to establish four military bases in Spain.
In return, Spain was allowed to join NATO.
In the same year, Franco got recognition by
the smallest – but by no means powerless
– State in the world: the Vatican.
Pope Pius XII granted Franco the right to
appoint Spanish bishops from a list of several
candidates proposed by the Holy See.
In 1956 Morocco gained independence, after
being a French protectorate.
The Moroccan government demanded authority
also over the Sidi-Ifni territory, one of
the last remnants of Spanish possessions in
North Africa.
Franco denied this concession, as ever willing
to preserve at least a slice of the Empire.
Morocco reacted by creating a Moroccan Liberation
Army, which engaged the Spanish garrison in
a series of skirmishes, until the Generalisimo
ordered the intervention of paratroopers from
the motherland.
The war – known as the ‘Spanish forgotten
war’ – dragged on into 1958, with even
the French Army and Air Force joining Franco
in February.
By April the Moroccans had been defeated,
but Spain was pressured by the UN and the
US to hand back the region of Tarfaya.
Spain retained control of Sidi-Ifni until
1969, when it returned the former colony to
Morocco following a UN resolution.
In 1963 Franco had launched a program to soften
his totalitarian regime, in a bid to further
improve relationships with the West, and the
US in particular.
He terminated the activities of military tribunals
and had them replaced with civilian courts.
He also shut down the special courts created
to trial Communists and Freemasons.
Other reforms included laws supporting a partial
freedom of the press and freedom of worship.
Until then, the regime had actively suppressed
the activities of all opposition: left wing
parties, trade unions and regional separatists,
who were very vocal especially in the Basque
country and Catalunya.
Franco’s reforms and ouvertures to the West
had succeeded in stabilising the country and
the economy.
Repression of dissenters was toned down, but
the Generalisimo still maintained a tough
stance against separatism.
In August of 1965 President Johnson asked
for Spain’s participation in the Vietnam
War.
The Caudillo rejected the invitation, logically
wary of engaging in guerrilla warfare in a
far-away jungle.
But he did order for a team of field medics
to join the war.
Meanwhile, Franco, his advisor Luis Carrero
Blanco and prince Juan Carlos, were planning
the succession.
Their plan was to formally reveal the Bourbon
prince as future king in January 1969, but
this was delayed due to a series of terrorist
attacks from ETA, the Basque separatist.
Finally in July Franco formally announced
that Juan Carlos of Bourbon would succeed
him as head of State and King of Spain.
In a televised ceremony, the prince swore
an oath of loyalty to the Caudillo and to
the Nationalist Movement.
By 1973 Franco was 81 and not able to handle
the day to day administration of the Government.
He appointed Carrero Blanco as his Prime Minister,
maintaining an active role in some foreign
policy matters.
Carrero Blanco’s office was short lived:
on the 20th of December his car was blown
up by ETA, in an explosion so violent that
the car flew over a church and landed on a
2nd floor terrace.
A macabre joke started to circulate in Spain:
‘Arriba España, Arriba Franco … más
alto que Carrero Blanco!’
Arriba meaning ‘long live’ but also ‘up
with’.
So, it can be translated as
‘Up with Spain, Up with Franco … even
higher than Carrero Blanco!”
The subsequent crackdown on ETA led to five
terrorists being sentenced to death and executed
in September of 1975.
These death penalties caused massive demonstrations
in Madrid, Lisbon and the Basque city of San
Sebastian, as well as international condemnation.
Franco had firmly backed these, and future
executions.
The dissent, the demonstrations, even the
jokes … all these were clear signs that
times had definitely changed since the totalitarian
days of the 1940s and 1950s.
The regime, regardless of the Caudillo’s
age, was nearing its end.
Last Words
Generalisimo Francisco Franco Bahamonde had
been a reluctant leader who had gained control
on the back of his brother’s schemes.
He had been a nostalgic of the Empire, ready
to bargain his country’s entry in WWII to
regain North Africa.
He had been the ruthless Caudillo who could
not tolerate opposition.
And finally, the astute politician who had
sought to bring stability to a divided nation.
Francisco Franco died on the 20th November
of 1975, of natural causes.
His last words were reported as
“I ask pardon of all my enemies, as I pardon
with all my heart all those who declared themselves
my enemy, although I did not consider them
to be so”
In his last conversation with Prime Minister
Navarro, he asked for the Spanish people to
rally around their new King Juan Carlos and
‘to keep the lands of Spain united’.
The Spanish did give their support to Juan
Carlos, who successfully led the transition
to a full democracy.
I am aware that Francisco Franco and the Civil
War remain a divisive topic to this day in
Spain, so before I leave I will kindly ask
you not to turn the comments section into
a rhetoric battle.
Why don’t you use the comments instead to
suggest another character from the Civil War,
maybe on the Republican side?
That’s it from me, I hope you enjoyed this
video and as usual … thank you for watching!